uh guys i stayed up way too late last
night trying to binge watch this entire
series like it did
exactly what a great
fun crime mystery drama is supposed to
do so congrats on that and number two
i don't
how many episodes did you see
i saw what
i started at three in the morning yeah
that's what it was i saw i saw six
before i was like i gotta i gotta
actually have a brain working tomorrow
so i actually am saving for myself for
today like the conclusion of the series
i'm very very excited uh steve where did
this idea come from
well like all ideas you just kind of
don't know i mean so you somebody issues
a challenge like say said friend said
you should write something for these
three actors and the idea just pops in
your head you know and you kind of work
on it
you don't really
sit at a computer or add a typewriter or
a piece of paper anything you just kind
of think about it and then it either
grows in your mind or it doesn't and
this just kind of kept growing enough to
a point where i sort of reluctantly
pitched it to a producer
and and as soon as i said the idea
you get the feeling that everybody went
hmm not bad
uh even myself you know because i'd
never really heard it out loud so anyway
and then it just grew and got brilliant
people john hoffman coming in dan
fogelman and then marty and selena and
and it just starts to take off it grows
like somebody described the movie once
it's locomotive once it starts you can't
stop it
and this has that feeling in a good
sense
yeah you know one of the great moments
early on
which took me right back to when
everyone in the whole world was
listening to the season one of cereal
was when the three of your characters
start clicking together that you all
love the same thing right is that how
reflective is that
of real life when it comes to these true
crime podcasts are you are you guys
addicted to them as well or what martin
i'm like
a podcast freak
he's lying i actually am
marty is the least
and selena is the second most yes
but you know it's not only uh podcasts
true prime pockets there's true crime
television and as i say it's not it's
not the uh
uh the horror of it that i'm interested
in it's the solving that i find to be so
interesting
modern technology for solving
yeah and there are a lot of throwbacks
to even with just the mention like the
the constant mention of this hardy voice
hardy boys thing is
something that you know a particular
audience will latch on to selena i'm
wondering for you you have an audience
of people that have followed you in your
career every step that you've made every
change that you've made and here you are
now doing this one what do you hope that
your fans that have followed you for a
long time love about mabel
uh well i i hope they
thought i did a good job you know um
that's all i could hope for
i i loved playing mabel i very similar
to the character to be honest so
i'm just excited to be back on tv and to
you know be a part of this cast
there are a uh delicious number of
f-bombs in this show
and they're all very like each and every
one of them is like very intentional
like there's a character behind each and
every one of them is there
is there a particular satisfaction
in getting to
express with that language on a tv
series
martin
why is it a big deal
i just loved it just it was just the way
that
they each came out i just it stuck out
to me and i thought it was really just a
fun you know detail uh i'll i'll answer
because i you know
as a movie writer i was thinking
how much of this can you say or do you
even want to say in the movies i don't
even want to say it and i'd protect
myself like i'm not going to put the f
word in and then i'd go see a play
and then say it and i'd realize it just
went by everybody nobody objected nobody
left nobody felt anything
uh so i think i think that you know
there was a time when they would
sell hill street blues a special sweeps
episode where the word bull
is said
you know
and i think we're just a long long way i
mean we've been hearing
all language on cable
television for
35 years now so i don't think there's a
big big stretch i think it almost
artistic or freedom or anything like
that who cares you don't need it
but if it seemed to whenever i said it
it felt
yeah
he would say that right now and it's
it's not emphasized it's just passed by
but but to come
when um you know when older actors saw
people on television not saying gee
that's a super pair of hat
danny you know i mean people change with
each generation of how they speak and
and the words they use
yeah it's just the way people talk yeah
correct
selena you've described your
relationship with these two gentlemen as
them being your crazy uncles
and
if i
for my crazy uncles one of the things
they love doing is just giving me advice
about something whether solicited or not
is there anything that these guys
just said to you that you know this
maybe took you off guard as a as a fun
piece of advice anything oh i think that
steve suddenly like
he's he like makes fun of
himself
in a way
um what was the question
i knew you were lost yeah
it was any sorry i really don't know
any funny
i didn't i did
all the stuff you learned from us i
think that was it yeah what have you
learned from us
and does steve ever overstep his bounds
boundaries and giving too much advice
yes no i had the best time i just feel
like i'm saying the same thing so i'm
just gonna give it much feel it is so
awesome to work with people who have
been doing this for so long and they're
incredibly humble and incredibly kind
and professional
and they've taught me if anything have
just set an example
of what um a gentleman is and what
a kind
actor
hear that carlos
so i i have to take your example now all
the time on how to be how to be a
gentleman i'll gladly do that gladly
good
steve and and martin you know we love
watching your career watching you guys
come up together doing all these
different projects over the years what's
the secret to
um
to a really great professional
relationship that lasts such a long time
no jealousy
kindness and instinct of kindness yeah
not neurotic with each other right i
mean if we're working on our live show
and there's a funny line that mighty
might say no that's a line for you or
i'll say that's a line for you we're not
fighting for lines or
anything we know that i think working
with steve i've learned um
the importance of faking a laugh for
example
pretending like i'm funny pretending
like the other guy's funny mm-hmm
pretending
does it
you know that weird time where you like
with a friend you want to hire someone
to have him eliminated
the shoulder rubbing
what
no no never mind ignore that part go on
with the three of you being so musically
inclined and musically talented steve
there's all these instruments on set and
you play like every single one ever
invented i in my mind this was a very
musical set
was it is that true was there singing
and performing
when the cameras were off
almost never
no
marty would sing all the time
all the time and so does selena i mean
martin marty sings his breakfast order
[Laughter]
no no i would say there was a lot of
when you think of it a lot of just if
you're in the elevator
um
i would be singing or selena would be
singing yeah
i love that well i'm looking forward to
finishing the series
tonight thank you so much for your time
the three of you
all the best thank you thank you very
much bye carlos
you